my name's Simon stone I'm a maintainer
on a project called hyper ledger
composer which is our framework for
building block chain solutions quick
question or quick round of questions
rather who's heard of hyper ledger
composer before Oh a couple of hat has
anyone actually tried it out no okay and
that's a shame
who's heard of blockchain Oh lots more
hands excellent who's heard a bit coin
pretty much the whole room right
excellent
has anyone aside from high political
posers anyone tried building blockchain
apps before whether a Bitcoin or
etherium or quarter yeah couple of hands
okay good and so I'm going to show you
oh one final question who knows how to
cope JavaScript yeah so I'm gonna show
you how you as standard JavaScript
developers can build a blockchain
solution but first a quick round of
blockchain introduction and this is
going to be very quick so what is
blockchain in one sentence is just a
trusted distributed ledger a record of
transactions that occur in a network and
why do we need this well this is an
example of a business network today you
can see we've got six participants
participant a and B terrible names but a
bank an insurance company a regulator
and an auditor and they all maintain
their own Ledger's their own log of the
transactions that they make within this
business network and this is inefficient
it's expensive and everyone is recording
the same log of transactions there is
also a bit of a problem here because if
someone's records disagrees with someone
else's there's no resolution apart from
good to go to the court and be like well
my ledger says this your ledger says
that what do we do and blockchain solves
this by giving us a shared replicated
ledger where there is one ledger we all
have a copy of it and we can all update
it but in this case it's permissioned as
well so I I only have permission to see
what I'm allowed to see on that ledger
so for example the bank might only have
access to see bank records for people
who bank with that
that's a lot of uses of the word Bank
the regulator might have access to see
everything but might not have access to
update the ledger
whereas participant a might have very
limited access to the ledger in order to
just solve transactions for their bit of
business and blockchain provides four
key characteristics consensus everyone
has to agree on the changes that get
recorded on the ledger provenance you
can use the blockchain ledger to track
the history of an asset see where it
came from
immutability once something gets
recorded on the blockchain ledger it's
there forever and that's guaranteed by
the blockchain and finality the
blockchain is the single source of truth
there's no our way says that on the
blockchain but I'll go check my ledger
the ledger should be the source of truth
the blockchain ledger should be the
source of truth rather and I asked about
Bitcoin because bitcoin is really
important
it's the it's an unregulated shadow
currency for those of you that haven't
tried it out but it's the first
blockchain application iBM is not
interested in Bitcoin or cryptocurrency
for that matter but what we are
interested in is the technology to
underpins Bitcoin that was introduced in
around 2008 and we've really focused on
using that blockchain technology to
enhance business processes and
blockchain for business differs from
blockchain for crypto currencies and a
couple of key areas
it offers identity over our normality in
Bitcoin nobody knows who you are
you're just a certificate block think of
in blockchain for business because we're
in a business network we're dealing with
parties that we already know and trust a
bit more reputation is on the stake if I
screw up or start trying to put invalid
data into the ledger then my reputation
is going to suffer and I'm going to lose
customers and business Bitcoin uses a
consensus algorithm called proof of work
which is very resource-intensive
essentially miners have to compete by
solving mathematical problems using
hashing in order to add blocks to the
blockchain when they do this they are
rewarded with bitcoins mining fees you
need that for a pub
untrusted Network where everyone is
anonymous because anyone could be trying
to update the ledger to transfer funds
in there to their benefit whereas in
blockchain for business there's a
limited set of participants just those D
duelling doing business with each other
and so we can use a less
resource-intensive consensus mechanism
we call it selective endorsement where
only the party's interested in the
transaction maybe the buyer the seller
their banks and maybe the regulator sign
off on the transaction before it gets
recorded to the blockchain we're
interested in tracking assets just
assets in general whatever kind of
assets those might be rather than crypto
currencies there are four main
requirements for a blockchain for
business those are a shared ledger the
immutable log of transactions that
everyone gets access to the smart
contract the code that governs that
ledger who can update it what updates
are allowed to make what transactions
are occurring in this network privacy
the rules around who can see what data
in the blockchain finally trust the
knowledge that changes are only made and
committed to the blockchain if people
have signed off on them and what
benefits does this bring
well for starters it saves time many
business processes today are still based
on paper you still have to send letters
off and this is clearly inefficient so
blockchain makes certain transactions go
from weeks and months down to days hours
and minutes removes cost there's no
overhead you don't have to manage your
Ledger's anymore reduces risk of people
tampering with your ledger and finally
increases trust through shared processes
regulators now have or regulators can
now block use blockchain to gain full
insight into what's occurring in a
business network not just the
information that they request be sent to
them those of you where the key now may
notice I'm not wearing an IBM t-shirt
I'm wearing a hyper ledger t-shirt so
those of you that aren't aware hyper
ledger is an umbrella project started by
the Linux foundation to build blockchain
technologies for businesses started in
December 2015 and it's grown rapidly
since then IBM were one of the starting
members
we're now over 140 members it's all
based around open source and open
standards and it's a set of seven or
eight projects under the hyper layer
project now one of them is fabric hyper
laser fabric which is a blockchain
technology one of them is composer but
there are other projects there as well
and there's a big list of members of hi
pleasure you'll see IBM on the left but
some other big names as well
Intel JPMorgan our free American Express
and this list keeps getting updated on a
regular basis which is great to see so
now on to the important bits hi pleasure
composer is a framework to accelerate
the development of solutions on top of a
blockchain platform such as hyper ledger
fabric and why do we need that in the
past it's traditionally being very
difficult to build blockchain solutions
on top of the existing technologies it's
very technical and it's very new it's
it's proven difficult we speak to a lot
of clients over the past couple of years
where they have really struggled they
have great use cases but they really
struggled to take those use cases and
turn them into working pocs or even
production deployments and composer our
emphasis from a start was really on
enabling people to deliver solutions
quickly using a business centric
vocabulary so before the blockchain
solutions were all very technical is
based around a key value pair map but
now we want them to focus at their
business use case level so they're
focusing on the assets the participants
and transactions that occur within their
business network that are trying to port
to blockchain we've given them business
centric API so they can build
applications around a blockchain
business network and they can use those
API to submit transactions create assets
or update assets remove assets and work
with participants and permissions as
well and all of that data gets stored on
the blockchain both in the ledger and in
a database called the world state we've
also got some tools that allow you to
easily integrate blockchain solutions
with your existing systems of record
many of the companies adopting
blockchain have been around for a very
long time and
have existing systems whether that's
like EAP enterprise or ERP systems like
sa P or Internet of Things devices and
they need to bring the data from those
systems to the blockchain as well and so
we've built quite a extensive and open
development toolset that most of you
will probably be quite familiar with
starting with the unfamiliar thing in
the top left we built a custom domain
specific language that allows you to
model your business network this is a
composer modeling language we've enabled
you to write your business logic in
smart contracts using standard
JavaScript we have a web-based
playground for learning composer trying
it out testing your business Network in
your solution we have some client
libraries for building applications
those are no js' libraries we have some
editor plug-ins for a couple of popular
editors ass women Visual Studio code we
have a command line and a composer
command we can do some cogeneration so
because we know what the blockchain
solution looks like because you've taken
a time to model that solution using the
composer modeling language we can
generate a scaler to an angular
application within a minute and finally
we have some integration technology
built on top of loopback and swagger
open standards for building REST API so
before I dive into the technical bits
I'm going to show you a quick demo drink
the first and this is a demo around a
vehicle lifecycle of a vehicle within a
network and you can see that we have
quite a few participants in our vehicle
tracking business Network we have Alex
from the agency for vehicle standards
Paul a buyer of a vehicle Debi the
vehicle regulator the DMV in the US
Tommen and insurer Mike the manufacturer
and Vardar from the police but we're
just going to focus on three key
participants in this demo we're gonna
focus on Paul who's going to buy a
vehicle from Mike whilst Debi the
regulator keeps a watchful eye over this
Paul's going to use a mobile app to
order his vehicle from Mike at areum
who's going to integrate his
chaim bits with enterprise integration
tools and ERP and the Internet of Things
he's enabled his he's got an existing
factory process that he's had for years
he started enabling with enabling it
with IOT to start tracking the lifecycle
of a vehicle as it moves through the
factory floor and finally Debbie is
going to use this new information stored
on the blockchain to perform analytics
and look for potential regulation fraud
look at the apps so this is Paul's view
of the blockchain he doesn't even know
he's using a blockchain this is just a
standard mobile application built with
ionic and angular I believe I'm not a UI
developer so and don't quiz me on those
parts and so we're gonna build a car and
we'll go for the area Nova anyone want
to pick some options standard or
executive trim the executive color
purple interior color rum good choice
extras tinted windows i recommended i
recommending extended warranty these REM
cars are a bit dodgy so i'm going to
click the purchase and build button so
what what happened when i click that
button was a transaction got submitted
to the blockchain to record that order
onto the ledger we can see that mike
from his merit man area manufacturing
dashboard has instant insight into this
order appearing in the blockchain
network you see does it popped up and
it's ready to start manufacturer most
importantly though we can see that the
transaction has been added to debbie's
regulatory dashboard view of the
blockchain so she can see and she has
instant insight into that water being
placed that's which has to mike and kick
off the manufacturing process this bit
requires a lot of imagination i'm afraid
there's no real factory floor tied to
this button and as we imagine the
vehicle moving through the factory floor
as events like the chassis being build
the chassis number being stamped to
intuit it going through the paint shop
we're going to submit a dish
all transactions to record those updates
onto the blockchain you'll see that
their status updates there Paul gets
instant insight into his vehicle
processing along but again importantly
it's not gonna refresh we can see that
Debbie gets instant insight into the
lifecycle of the factory before it's
even left it and finally she can see
that the vehicle has moved into
delivered State so we've tracked the
whole ordering process from Paul
ordering from the application all the
way through to factory floor wood a way
to delivery and we've done it on a
blockchain Paul's being able to do that
without knowing anything what he's
interacting with Mike doesn't really
know that he's interacting with a
blockchain what the regulator has a full
insight to what's going on and that's
what's most important here so how do we
build this demo we built it using hyper
ledger composer which is a framework for
building blockchain applications and we
started off in this this is the composer
playground at the web tool for learning
composer and we had to build a set of
files that make up a blockchain solution
and the first of those are a model file
written in the composer modeling
language that describes everything you
just saw in that demo so it describes a
vehicle asset it describes a
manufacturing participant and it
describes some of the transactions that
occur in that business network so if I
click on PDA and an interesting bit
don't know of you guys because you know
let me just zoom in so here we've
modeled a vehicle asset this is a type
it's identified by a VIN a vehicle
number it's got some vehicle details a
status a relationship to the person who
owns that vehicle a number plate and
some other data as well we've modeled
some transactions so we have a
transaction for scrapping the vehicle or
transaction for updating suspicious
vehicles events as well so we can model
events that occur in a blockchain
business Network
once you've modeled everything in your
blockchain Business Network you need to
start implementing your business logic
and you do that with JavaScript for each
transaction that you define in a model
file you implement that logic so let's
take a look at an example so when Mike
clicked that button in the mobile
application to order his vehicle he
submitted a place order transaction to
the blockchain which then executed this
JavaScript code on that blockchain
network it's fairly simple
I hope it's fairly obvious all it does
it creates a new instance of the order
asset using a factory class fills out
some properties of that order and then
it stores it into an asset registry
recording it on the blockchain for
future use finally we create a new event
an instance of a place order event to
tell other applications that something
has happened in the blockchain that an
order has been placed so you can trigger
downstream processing based off of that
the other file which is not that great
to look at but is a permissions file who
can do what in this business network and
there's a very simple demo where we
simply said that everyone can do
everything in this network this is
connected to a real blockchain running
on my laptop we can see that by going to
the globe in the top left we defined a
connection profile that defines where
the blockchain network is where the
nodes that make up that blockchain run
once we've built everything in the
composer playground you might want to
switch to a more powerful maybe your
favorite editor and as I mentioned we've
built a couple of plugins for a couple
of editors so we have a Visual Studio
code plug-in it gives syntax
highlighting a bit of code completion
support and you can just work with your
composer artifacts as you would any
other standard JavaScript project we've
also enabled you to be able to unit test
your blockchain solutions built with
composer using standard JavaScript unit
testing tools so you can use maca to
write unit tests around your business
logic I scroll down so I have a test
that says checks that Alex can read all
of her assets in this network but we've
also written a step library using
cucumber so you can write a little more
friendly
for your business Network so given and
nice and simple so a lot easier for
those businesspeople that we're trying
to target with this solution to start
writing tests acceptance tests for
what's being built we can also integrate
it with standard code coverage tools
like Istanbul so here's the code
coverage report for our basic sample
network our hello world
you can simply see in the business logic
for our sample transaction what parts it
took just like any standard JavaScript
once we build those artifacts that make
up our blockchain business network we
can package them up and deploy it into
the blockchain at which at which point
they start becoming a running thing that
you can start interacting with but
that's not where we stopped we wanted to
enable developers to build solutions
around that as well in the first part of
any proper solution is being able to
build a REST API for it so we started
off with a technology called loopback is
everyone familiar with loopback so
loopback is just a framework for
generating REST API from a variety of
back end systems like databases and we
built a loopback connector for composer
that allows you to connect to a running
Business Network deploy to blockchain
and generate a REST API for it in a
matter of seconds really and we package
that up into a single easy-to-use
command when you run that you get your
familiar swagger UI at which point you
can start writing applications against
the REST API so for each type you define
in your network we generate a REST API
for it so we have REST API surround
orders around manufacturer participants
around all of the transactions as well
you can also take this REST API and
enable it for authentication using
passports at passport has 300 different
strategies for integrating with your
existing authentication providers and
will take care of the mapping between
those users and the blockchain users for
you so you don't have to worry about
those parts because loopback is all
standards-based it also generates a
swagger document for your blockchain
business network at which point you can
plumb it into any tool that uses
my favorite one is the swagger coach in
if you don't want to use JavaScript you
might want to use Java or.net that way
inclined and so you can use swagger
coach n to quickly generate an SDK for
your programming language of choice so
once you have a running REST API you
really want to start building some
client applications that interact with
that blockchain business network and we
really wanted to give users a hand
helping hand brother and we've done that
using a plug-in for yeoman so you can
use the yeoman generator to generate an
angular application from a running
business network I'm sure most of you
have seen it but it has a cool
command-line you just say yo - ledger
composer and it's going to ask you some
questions do you want to connect to a
running Business Network yes some
information about the project to create
license which network I want to connect
to lots of questions and it goes off it
connects to that blockchain business
network and it generates an angular 2
application or angular 4 or other
application with a set of UI components
for all of the types that you've defined
in that network so you can see this is
our perishable goods sample and we
generated an angular component for a
shipment asset and a component for a
contract asset I'm gonna cancel the npm
install because i'm not connected to the
Internet but here's one I prepared
earlier
it's not pretty to look at we haven't
spent a lot of time on the UI design for
this one I'm afraid
but importantly you get a menu in the
top right that gives you a list of all
of the types in this network or just the
assets in this case and then you get
some generated components that allow you
to interact with the blockchain so we've
got a table that lets you work with
shipments now you can see there's a
shipment already stored on a blockchain
for some bananas and then we generate
some forms for adding updating and
deleting assets from the blockchain
as well now whilst it's not very pretty
- look look at it shows any UI developer
how to interact with the blockchain
easily and they can take that and apply
some proper UX and UI design to
it finally I mentioned that the
manufacturer has some existing business
processes that we need to integrate with
and for those of you that saw the next
talk earlier we've built some nodes for
node red that allow you to wire up
various systems with your blockchain
business network to scroll down to the
pallet we can see them there the free
hyper ledger composer nodes they allow
you to subscribe to events from a
blockchain business network as well as
submit transactions and retrieve assets
and participants from the blockchain
scroll across so this bit of the flow at
the top take some input from a WebSocket
that's a bit of transformation and then
submit an order to the blockchain so
this is the node-red flow behind pools
mobile application that he used to order
is vehicle that's it for the demo and if
I just finish off on some slides
everything we do is open source
everything you've just seen is open
source and available today we released
it in March and it was accepted into
hyper ledger as a top-level projects as
soon after everything we do is tracked
in github you can see our plans for the
future and our current list of issues
and we'd love for you to come along and
participate I have a comment on what
we're doing provide feedback
contributions are gladly welcomed and
start planning to help us start planning
to build for the future we also have
weekly calls and they run on an
alternating schedule we're in the UK so
we get to cover most of the world that
way we have a late afternoon call for us
and an early morning call for us but
that lets us get America and Japan and
everything in between so and what we
really like about those calls is not
just a chance for us to talk about what
we're doing it's a chance for our users
to come along and show us what they're
building with composure we're all over
the Internet we're easy to find in
search engines nowadays but you can find
everything we've got a website a web
page Rover on the hypoplasia website
we've got our main main Doc's page it's
got some tutorials and some
documentation that help you get going
with composer
there's a publicly hosted version of
that playground that development tool on
bluemix that you can connect to and try
out without having to install anything
and you'd find all our source code and
NPM modules in the usual places
finally you can come and speak to us
we're in rocket chair which is an
open-source alternative slack that's run
by the hyper ledger team we have a
couple of channels in there we've got a
Stack Overflow tag you can ask us
questions on and you can also tweet us
as well yeah thank you very much
blockchain in about 25 minutes so thank
you are there any questions
[Applause]